there was a a guy in a turtleneck who
went viral on tick-tock the other day
because he was claiming
that jesus lord and redeemer
second person of the blessed trinity
is a racist take a listen did you know
that there's a part of the gospel of
mark where jesus
uses a racial slur in mark chapter seven
there's the account of the seraphinian
woman
a woman who is syrian and greek both of
which there were strong biases against
within the jewish community
and she comes to ask jesus to heal her
daughter who's possessed by a demon
and what is jesus's response he says
it's not good for me to give the
children's food meaning the children of
israel's food
to dogs he calls her a dog
what's amazing about this account is
that the woman doesn't back down
she speaks truth to power she confronts
jesus and says
well you can think that about me but
even dogs deserve the crumbs from the
table
her boldness and bravery to speak truth
to power actually changes jesus mind
jesus repents of his racism and extends
healing to this woman's daughter
i love this story because it's a
reminder that jesus is human he had
prejudices and bias
and when confronted with it he was
willing to do his work
and this woman was willing to stand up
and speak truth
is that what happened uh you know
i've read the same gospel account i
that's
not exactly what happened as far as i i
can tell
what happens of course is
something like what he described happens
and then christ
says it's not not fit to give this to
dogs
and she begs and she pleads and she says
in the gospel according to saint matthew
yes lord yet even the dogs eat the
crumbs that fall from their master's
table
then jesus answered her o woman great is
your faith
be it done for you as you desire and her
daughter was healed
instantly she did not change
jesus's mind had this young man
gone on to read the gospel according to
saint john he would have known this
because john begins
uh very first lines by proclaiming
that uh christ is the divine
logic of the universe logic
itself the word of god so you can't
change
christ's mind because he is logic he
is the reason the fundamental reason
that undergirds reality
now he does show
to this woman and to others uh her faith
and uh he does uh show our brokenness
and his
grace he does all of that this wonderful
this cause to be rejoicing
it's cause to say yes oh my gosh i can't
believe it i
miserable sinner me i will say with such
gratitude that i have been redeemed
through really no uh help of my own
other than
uh responding to god's grace with an act
of faith
god comes to me like christ was near
this woman and
she responds to that in an act of faith
and he says oh great great is your faith
be it done as you desire
or you can say god is a racist
those are the two options the the one
option
will save your soul and our entire
civilization and built our entire
civilization
the other option does really well on
tick tock
and uh our culture seems to be choosing
the latter
there are two particular heresies here
that this guy is espousing and the
reason i
i mention it is because it it pervades
our political culture
the heresies are aryanism which denies
the divinity of christ
there's a very famous account from the
council of nicaea where saint nicholas
santa claus
punches the arch-heretic arius in the
face because he doesn't want to take it
no more
and and the other the other heresy is
pelagianism the idea that this woman
earned
her salvation that you can earn your
your salvation through
works which sometimes certain protestant
denominations accuse the catholic church
of doing
but that's just not true the catholic
church condemned the heresy of pelagius
many many moons ago these are heresies
that have infected our modern culture we
deny
divinity we deny the divinity of christ
undergirding our civilization and also
we're really impressed with ourselves
and we think that we can save ourselves
this is the motivating principle behind
communism
behind so many of our modern ideologies
and it's
it uh also speaks to our pride that we
have now used to be considered the queen
of all vices now it's
elevated as such a high virtue that we
have parades dedicated
to pride if you enjoyed that video be
sure to hit the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube knows that we've got
the absolute top content out there